not all 5g is made the same so there's a
speed there's a there's a bandwidth
thing
and then there's coverage how many
people get to enjoy
um today and how does the progress in
the next 5 10 20 30 50 years you think
it looks like in terms of coverage great
topic conversation so let's talk about
this
when i meet with regulators
across the globe i i tell them
resistance is futile allocate every
spectrum to
wireless every spectrum needs to be
allocated to wireless the reality is
when we start moving from cdma to
ofdma
we knew that
there's this industry has done a lot to
get more bits per hertz but the reality
is
the massive amount of improvements that
is required
in capacity and in speed
you need more spectrum you know there's
there's not so much we can rely on more
bits per hertz you just need more
spectrum and if you look
for example what carriers since the 2g
era they participate in different
license and auctions and every spectrum
they accumulated from 2g or 3g or 4g
all of that you may be able to get one
or two channels max of sub 6
which is a channel is about 100
megahertz or 200 megahertz and that's it
so
we we need more spectrum so 5g has been
designed to work across every spectrum
from the low frequency bands that's what
we call the sub 6
but you needed more you needed to go to
the millimeter wave so that's why
five five g is a technology that you can
deploy from 450 megahertz as an example
or 600 or 700 uh all the way to in the
42
gigahertz
and that's where millimeter wave comes
into the picture now
let's now connect this to your question
about coverage uh of 5g
the easiest thing to do uh is to deploy
5g in the new spectrum you can get
which is uh in the sub 6 you see bands
being auctioned across the globe into
3.5 gigahertz
there's nothing special about the band
is it's the only one that was available
because everything else being used for
4g
and you can deploy on that go into
existing cell towers and just put a new
equipment without having to build new
towers but when we go to technology such
as millimeter wave then you have to
build more dense networks you need to
build more stations because the
deployment in that case look like a
wi-fi deployment it's almost like wi-fi
access points when you need to build
more stations you need permits you need
to build
fiber so it takes more time to densify
so what you see happening is coverage
has been built fast with subjects
across the globe now the united states
also have the sub-six
so that gets you the coverage very fast
but millimeter wave it's moving and uh
if you always say for example verizon
the united states has had a leadership
uh in building millimeter wave it takes
time i'll say cities like uh chicago
manhattan starting to get coverage
it will be a process over a number of
years as you build
uh those different access points type
networks but it's inevitable
there's not enough spectrum so every 5g
operators just a matter of time we'll
have millimeter wave as well resistance
is futile okay so uh for millimeter wave
we need density of access points
and
what's the biggest resistance
for qualcomm
for human civilization
is it uh politicians regulators federal
regulators
is it uh individual humans as it's not
enough money from the consumer
perspective like what who is the biggest
pain in the butt
from a qualcomm standpoint but answering
the question about what it takes to
build all this technology
i think regulators across the board
understood the importance of 5g i have
not met a regulator that said it's
really important to be late on 5g i
don't think anybody wants to be late on
5g and as a result we've seen enormous
amount of progress in getting spectrum
allocated to 5g
i think the real issue is the time that
it takes to build infrastructure you
know investment in 5g infrastructure
special millimeter wave is like building
roads and ports it's critical
infrastructure and those things take
time like one of the number one obstacle
you're going to hear from operators is
psy permit
you know sometimes they have to
negotiate municipality by municipality
about permits to get new cell sites but
you know the networks will be densified
and
and you're going to need all of the
capacity for the promise of the fully
immersive augmented reality that will
replace phones and everything being
connected 100 of the time
you